we've just learned the verdict in the
derek chovin
trial and we will be coming to you live
with as many updates as possible right
now the verdict is
guilty uh on all charges ben tell us
what it means
so it means that i'm not sure whether
the the sentencing is cumulative
accumulative or whether it is
or whether it is they take the top
sentence and then everything else falls
under that but
uh because he doesn't have a criminal
record that means he maxes out at twelve
and a half years for second degree
murder 12 and a half years for third
degree murder
four years or so for the manslaughter
charge
um it was pretty obvious from how fast
the jury came back that it was going to
be guilty on all accounts as soon as
they said the jury was coming back today
i immediately said to my producers and
publicly that it was going to be
guilty on all accounts because they were
never going to acquit on all accounts
that quickly if there had been an
acquittal it would have taken a while to
get there
uh my own prediction was that if there
had been any sort of real evidentiary
consideration which i
frankly do not think that there probably
was in this case it was a three-week
trial there were 10
hours of consideration that is wildly
disproportionate in a case that has this
many conflicting
patterns um that if they came back this
fast it would be a guilty verdict
i thought any jury that looked at this
would probably
have gone hung jury on the on the two
murder charges
and then may be convicted on the
manslaughter charge uh if you were going
to get very aggressive that would be an
aggressive jury if you were not
aggressive juror you would have
hung on all three counts um and if it
hung on all three accounts if you hung
it all
then the judge would have instructed
them to keep going back in the jury room
trying to beat it out because the fact
is that
you need a unanimous verdict for either
acquittal or for conviction
uh in in minnesota the fact that it was
unanimous that quickly meant
pretty clearly that it was going to be
conviction on all charges coming out
you know we'll have to see whether
people who had you know spent their
nights planning for rioting and looting
now
actually go home or whether they go
ahead and hit the local target in
celebration presumably
uh of of the verdict um but i think one
thing is pretty clear for anybody who
watched this
case closely i don't know how closely
watched a drew or jeremy i know matt you
watched it really closely
uh for people who watched this case
closely there were elements here
that it's very difficult to make the
case to me
that any rational jury would have
who just looked at the evidence would
have come to the conclusion that beyond
reasonable doubt
chovin was guilty of second or third
degree murder this just did not fulfill
the elements the third degree murder
charge particularly is absurd on its
face the third degree murder charge
never should have been allowed in the
courtroom
the third degree murder charge is is a
charge uh for what is generally called
depraved heart murderer depraved her
murder
is you throw a brick onto a freeway and
you don't have
anybody you're explicitly attempting to
kill but you end up killing somebody on
the freeway
you shoot a gun into a crowd that's
depraved heart murder and that was what
the third degree murder charge was
you have to have intent to kill others
right and then you end up killing one
person
it was counted anyway it shouldn't have
been on the t it shouldn't have been on
the docket the second degree murder
charge required felony assault
that results in the murder so usually
that is where you're robbing a store
you got a gun the gun accidentally goes
off and kills somebody right or
the guy dies for some other reason well
you're in the process of committing some
sort of felony so you had to show that
he intended to commit a felony
against george floyd it's very difficult
to say that he intended to commit a
felony against george floyd because
minneapolis police department procedure
allows you to do exactly what chovin was
doing
under these circumstances the
manslaughter one was a little bit easier
to make because of the charges
in that in the manslaughter case yeah
just have to have reckless disregard so
the the prosecution can make the case
that even if he didn't mean to do
anything bad it was reckless for him not
to get off of floyd
once floyd was already unconscious and
once floyd was dying
he should have gotten off of him and was
reckless not to get off of him but
the fact that they convicted on all
three counts as to me that they weren't
really looking
at the evidence because again all three
of those charges also rely on a simple
question of causation right did george
floyd actually die because derek chauvin
was was on top of him with his knee what
the defense showed repeatedly is that he
did not have his knee on his neck
right there was no physical trauma to
his trachea there was no evidence that
there had been physical trauma
to his uh to his arteries that would
have cut off the oxygen to the brain
uh there are a couple different types of
asphyxia there's there's physical
asphyxia where you actually strangle
somebody
there's you deprive somebody of oxygen
to the brain by cutting off their blood
supply
uh via their via their arterial blood
flow right and then there is
a chemical asphyxia which is drug
overdose
and and the fact is that george floyd
had three times the
deadly level of fentanyl in a system he
was high as a kite he had 75
arterial blockage the medical examiner
originally said if i found him dead in
his room i would have immediately
assumed
that it was a drug overdose right and
the only reason that this became
a national issue is because of the tape
which on its face when everybody first
saw it looks really ugly
because it turns out that a lot of
policing looks really ugly
and then when you get all of the lead up
at the very least you don't have to say
that you love what chovin did you don't
have to say that the chovin acted
appropriately you don't say any of that
stuff what you do have to say is
to not even believe that there's
reasonable doubt on the murder charges
on the murder charges
where you'd have to have intent that
suggested me that this was far less
about the actual facts of the case and
far more about all of the hubbubs
surrounding the case
this trial never should have taken place
in minneapolis it should have
immediately been transferred
in terms of venue you were not going to
find an impartial jury in minneapolis in
the single most publicized criminal
justice case
of our lifetime at least since rodney
king